big night big new show why was this the
show to do together oh it was it was
meant to be because we weren't really
talking that much we talked a little bit
but we didn't really know each other
anymore really and this helped us to get
to know each other again
and it was wonderful and we also met
some really great people there too and
learned some very valuable lessons like
the rules of engagement and things that
you will see unfold on the show there's
nothing fake there is nothing scripted
about this show there's nothing fake or
scripted about me I know everything you
guys say about me I read all your
articles I don't have a publicist I am
him I'm the Joker and you guys are all
playing my game I was listening to you
talking over there saying you're playing
a little bit of a mind game with the
media maybe right now how are you doing
right now I don't know you got to note
new ink on your face your neck what's
the story behind that the story is that
Medusa was in Greek mythology was if you
if you had gaze well first of all she
was she was raped when do Sun and in the
Greek mythology if you look it up you'll
you'll you'll learn a lot about it but
with that being said Medusa is my
protector so if you if you want to come
at me with some negativity my Medusa
will stare you in the eye and turn you
into stone Timnath ology googler they're
all about positivity right now in the
Carter Family my Medusa is I don't know
Rihanna
you it's not me this is the love of my
life right here this is my date this is
a big I've watched the premiere of the
show this is a big step to have taken
from where you were when you walked into
that mansion to start therapy we've been
paying attention it's been a wild few
weeks for the family can I just ask how
the family is doing and what the hopes
for the future are you know the hopes of
the future are this don't come up me the
wrong way because I will I will fight to
protect my rights and what our four
brothers stood for but that being said
Aaron loves his family very much and
that's where his heart is at and that's
where he's coming from he's coming from
love and he's just wanting to see it
return so there is a new family member
in this family we saw the baby was born
do you have any well wishes or thoughts
for the expanded family absolutely
Cersei is a name that my mom and my dad
gave one of my Siamese cats but Nick
didn't know that for so cirse it's it's
it's another it's a Greek mythology name
too so you know it was a goddess well
and in regards to you know you know if
I'm gonna be really how do I put this
politically correct regards to what you
asked you know how am i doing you know
I'm just focusing on not breaking my
bomb
all right I know new music is out we've
got the show hours ago what's the next
thing for Aaron Carter is the music out
I've been dropping a new single every
week
sensational love anything dropped I
created all the visuals for them I
directed the visuals for them I produced
I produce all my own music
I put the live bass I mix it I master it
I've had the honor of working under Joel
deadmau5 for a short period of time and
it was great you've got love written
right here on your face are we looking
for love you know this actually means a
lion and my hair in my in my in my
native language in Scandinavia okay and
Danish so not everything is what it
seems
exactly that's the game that you're
playing I'm not playing your game you're
playing mine all right I think we got to
leave it there thank you guys so much
[Music]